لقد تحدثت بالفعل إلى مصدر مقرب من
الرئيس قال في وقت سابق من هذا المساء
إن الرئيس أعرب عن قلقه من
إمكانية عزله بسبب بعض
هذه القضايا التي
تحدثت عنها للتو ، فقد قال إنها اقتباس
احتمالية حقيقية وفقًا لهذا
المصدر  لكن في هذه المرحلة ، لا يرى
أنه متأكد من أنك رأيته في تلك
التغريدة حيث يشير إلى هذه
المدفوعات على أنها معاملة من
الواضح أنها تبسط الأمور
كثيرًا لأن مايكل كوهين قال
وهو أقر بالذنب في ذلك.
يعتقد وقد قال إنه تم
توجيهه لدفع هذه المدفوعات من قبل
الرئيس الآن حيث تسير الأمور من هنا
تحدثت إلى مصادر أخرى بالقرب
من البيت الأبيض وحذر المصدر الذي يقول
إنهم يعتقدون أن هناك
مستشارين يؤمنون داخل البيت الأبيض
أن العنصر الوحيد الذي يمكن أن يظل
مع هذا الرئيس هو هذه الانتهاكات المزعومة
لتمويل
الحملات الانتخابية هذه الجرائم المالية للحملة التي تم
الادعاء بها في ولاية ميتش  ael Cohen ،
لكن في هذه المرحلة لا يعتقدون
داخل البيت الأبيض أنه
سيكون كافياً للحصول على إدانة في
مجلس الشيوخ في إزالة التصويت
في مجلس الشيوخ ، قد يكون كافياً في
مجلس ديمقراطي لكنهم لا يفعلون ذلك
.  لا أعتقد أنه سيؤدي إلى نوع من
الدعم من الحزبين لعزل الرئيس
والذي يمكن أن يؤدي حقًا إلى
اتخاذ بعض الإجراءات الجادة للغاية في مجلس الشيوخ
لصالح الرئيس